so how it's British business reacting
this evening well with me now Stephen
Phipps and he's the chief executive the
manufacturers organization the EEF and
the Institute of Directors director of
policy Edwin Morgan general good to see
you both
Stephen let me star with you this is not
signed sealed and delivered yet the deal
is written it's not signed we have to
get a full agreement before the
transition settles we do so we're
looking for a ratification of this on
the 23rd later this week but we saw this
is a very good step forward today and
particularly we like the fact there was
give and take on both sides to get it to
get us to this point so from the
reaction from business has been quite
positive to today's nodes but had been
given that this isn't signed sealed and
delivered to businesses still have to
potentially plan for a No Deal scenario
well this is about another stage in
hopefully an orderly process out of the
EU so this will help it will help
prevent businesses from at least say
they're really drastic decisions that we
wanted to avoid but and but there are
still many stages has to be ratified it
has to go through October final legal
ratification and then we also need to
know exactly what this transition phase
will look like we told standstill but
there are a few few details so to be
peeled out so Stephen the transition
period is three months shorter than the
UK government was looking for is that an
issue as far as you're concerned well
you know it's there's lots to do between
now and the final arrangements and in
many respects from from a point of view
of business the longer the period of
certainty whilst that is going on the
better but of course we'll have to see
how the negotiations go as I said I was
quite positive by the fact that we saw
lots of give-and-take in this phase so
hopefully that's going to be the spirit
in which we're going forward to is 21
months going to be enough though for
businesses to get everything teed up
well it depends how that again it all
depends it depends how this negotiation
unfolds from this point typically if you
look at free-trade agreements they take
a lot longer than that and that period
to negotiate but we are looking for a
unique and special arrangement going
forwards here and that's what the
government is is promising and we would
be there to support them to try to do
that Edwyn the for the freedom to
negotiate free trade deals during the
transition period I mean that is a major
ticking the box for the UK isn't it
absolutely I think I think we were
saying it's a bit of a Pro Matic
give or take from the EU as well I think
you know trade deals do take a while so
in the meantime we should be focusing on
actually the areas of a kind of
cooperation we can do with countries
like the US which fall short of a trade
deal there's loads of stuff the
government can be doing now and actually
the partner interest rate is doing some
good stuff so don't always just focus on
the F on the free trade agreements
there's stuff we can medially to boost
rating the short zone
of course this 21 month period the UK is
going to be in the words of Jacob Riis
morg a vassal state we will be a rule
taker not a rule maker I think we
perhaps always knew that this was always
its gonna be the way transition words it
was a necessary thing we had to happen
in order to prevent businesses from
having the hard falling out next year or
this year it's a stage we are leaving
the EU I think all of our members accept
that we know we're working towards a
different relationship with the EU it's
just make the process as smooth as you
can while we get there
one area that seems to be getting a lot
of people's backs up tonight is that
that doesn't seem to be much protection
for the UK's fisheries now albeit it's a
very very small part of the economy but
it's still hanging out there unsettled
as things are I think that's probably
going to happen with quite a few
different sectors as we go through this
process you know our members when we ask
them about it they want a deal which
covers all sectors the whole of the UK
so it there's going to be there's going
to be difficult moments like that where
one sector is feeling or you know where
we're being left behind but ultimately
the whole deal the deal has to focus on
the whole economy whole of the UK and
what's best for all of us Steven it
looks like the UK's given ground on
Northern Ireland we now have this back
stock position whereby there's a soft
border between northern land and the
Republic I mean that's something that
Theresa May said no Prime Minister could
agree agreed to I think it's another
example of the give-and-take that's been
really a characteristic of getting us to
this point and and in many respects that
is a good thing and we'll see that going
forwards of course this issue around the
borders and around customs arrangements
has yet to be resolved there's a lot of
hard hard yards to go before we end up
with a negotiation there and I think
what we're looking for is something
that's very unique and very innovative
and very different to the sort of models
that exist at the moment so there's
quite a lot of work to do to resolve
that and of course there's a
a great deal of hope that those backstop
situations will not occur but they've
written that in as a backstop
effectively so what's the next landmark
that you're looking out for well we want
formal ratification of this so we've got
the first council meeting happening this
week to say that that's greenlight and
then we've got the formal ratification
later in the year of the transition
agreement in the meantime there's a lot
of work to do so so business working
closely with government to work through
the details of how we negotiate now is a
very important part of the next steps in
all right Stephen Phipps and Edwin
Morgan good Ciro thanks for joining me
thank you